[Music]
today I'm going to show you how to make
a traditional mint julep one of the
oldest cocktails in existence and also
one of the best you just need three
ingredients bourbon mint and simple
syrup we're going to build this drink
right in the glass you can make it in a
glass like this this beautiful Kentucky
Derby silver cuff or ox glass works just
as well so we're going to start with a
pinch of mint eight to ten leaves half
an ounce of simple syrup
[Music]
and now muddle this just to extract the
aromatic oils in the mint but not to
pulverize it now we can add a bourbon
two and a half ounces of that when
making any cocktail measuring is really
important cocktails are all about
balance so it quote around in either
direction can sometimes make the
difference between a good and a really
bad drink so always measure if your
ingredients so we've got all our
ingredients in here and we want to add
our ice crushed ice really is best for
mint juleps because it melts a lot
faster and also stretches it out this is
a very stiff drink like 85% bourbon if
you don't have crushed ice at home you
could easily just crack some of the back
of a spoon or you can put it in a
blender or food processor but I really
recommend crushed ice just a few times
and then just give it a gentle stir just
to get that dilution going blend the
ingredients you eventually start to see
some frost appear on the outside of the
cup you'll know that the drink is ready
finish it off with a few more cubes on
top now we'll garnish it with the most
beautiful sprig of mint we can find and
you are all set and remember the mint
julep is not just for the Kentucky Derby
you can enjoy these all summer long if
you liked this video and you're looking
for more tips to step up your bartending
game subscribe to the GQ channel we've
got lots more where that came from
you
[Music]